i mean this is the hard thing after this
hard break to step up and continue
fighting right
i really really struggled
like unbelievably struggled from 2012 to
like 2014. i almost quit numerous times
i was so angry
i mean at one point
i got so mad at the ijf feeling like
they were [ __ ] me every step of the
way i threw a water bottle at a referee
after a match i cussed out a referee one
time on a mat i got suspended from the
sport because
i was just so angry at that point in
time and uh igf is the international
judo federation and they're are they the
people that supply the referees
basically like the they're kind of run
the sport they're on global scale
so
uh
you sent a few emails 2014 15
uh basically quitting one of them said
i'm mentally and physically broken
another said with the subject line i'm
done
yep the weight cuts didn't break you no
so if this broke you you were really
going through a hard time
i was like you know what
we're just gonna like dumb it down a
little bit and get some wins under our
belt i'm gonna go to a world cup
which is like three stages down or four
stages down from like
the olympic games like this should be
like a cake walk like making the final
of a world cup should be a walk in the
park
i show up
i barely beat a 16 year old kid
barely
then i got smoked in the second round i
got thrown three times
i was like i'm [ __ ] done they changed
all the [ __ ] rules they [ __ ] me out
of the olympics like
what am i supposed to do
and it was at that moment when i wrote
the email where
i remember sitting at a bar i don't
drink by the way but i was sitting at a
bar
at the hotel sending this email
and i got a response back from jimmy and
he goes well just
just stay for the training camp go to
germany and then whatever happens don't
worry about it we'll talk when you get
home
i was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] these people
[ __ ] the rules i don't [ __ ] care
anymore i'm just gonna do judo the way i
want to do judo if i [ __ ] get
shittoed out [ __ ] them
that was my response
can you become an olympic champion
can you become an olympic medalist with
that kind of thing can you think or no
was that
that's counterproductive yeah okay
just just checking because
maybe that's also liberating
the expectation was no longer that
travis is going to win this tournament
the expectation was travis is going to
come home and be [ __ ] pissed off
we're going to have to figure out how to
manage
a pissed off person that's trying to
quit that shouldn't be quitting
and do people still believe that you can
be a medalist again yeah like who
believed that jimmy believed it the team
managers believed it some of my
teammates still believed it
my training partner still did but
they're not the ones that are
cutting the weight
flying around
feeling like
you know all of your judo is now null
and void right because at this point
they took away leg grabs entirely
you couldn't break a grip with two hands
right the meta of judo has changed again
right so
i got [ __ ] out of it they took away
how i did judo again and now it just got
more difficult
so
when i'm sitting in the hotel and i'm
sending this email
i remember being at the training camp
like
i was like i don't even [ __ ] care
what the rules are i'm just gonna
[ __ ] throw people i don't even care
if i'm cheating doesn't matter to me
i'll just play stupid yeah
right so i just started going back and
doing judo without the leg grabs but
with all the same gripping that i was
doing
beforehand
and then when i got to germany i was
like i don't [ __ ] care i was like if
i gotta cheat to win then i gotta
[ __ ] cheat to win if i get cheetoed
out like then i get cheetoed out and i
won germany
uh which event in germany the german
grand prix which was yeah a week after
losing the world cup
because i was trying to
do judo around the new rule set
i wasn't just trying to do judo
right because when you get to the
highest level
your game tends to morph around
you know what can you can or cannot get
away with
i was more focused on trying to figure
out what i can and can't get away with
and i stopped actively doing judo
once i said [ __ ] whatever the rule
changes are i'm just going to keep doing
judo the way i know how to do judo and
if i get a penalty then so be it
and so that that win
that started the road back it wrote back
yeah because now it's like
i don't care if you penalize me or not
because
i'm gonna throw that guy anyways i'm
gonna beat him anyways
and if i get a shito for doing something
wrong
then i'll just stop doing that one thing
and just keep doing all the other things
that they told me i probably shouldn't
be doing but they're not calling me on
it so i'm just going to keep doing it
well
you uh
you found yourself it's a 2016 olympics
was that ever a doubt by the way after
this after 2014 in germany
i had a lot of doubt after the
concussion in 2015.
i remember
when i first came back after four months
of
nothingness that like
even trying to like train
the room would start to like tilt the
world on me
and then when i finally got over that
and i could start doing things again i
stepped on the mat
for the pan ams and i was like
drowning's not the right word but like
everything was being done in such a slow
motion like i had sandbags everywhere
that like i just couldn't keep up
like mental fog yeah like i remember
fighting the brazilian for
in the semi-final of pan ams
i was halfway through this match and i'm
just like
my eyes roll up i'm like i'm just gonna
[ __ ] wing it i just [ __ ] winged it
and i got countered and thrown free
phone and i was like
i don't even know what to do and i
couldn't even think clearly
and that's when i was like i may not
come back
yeah you don't have control over how to
come back from this it's like it's just
your mind and yeah it's not just not
operating not there it's not like i can
like oh my right hand's not working
because it's fractured let me figure out
a way i cannot use that like when your
mind's not working like
it's the one thing you need yeah like
you gotta have it so i can work through
anything else i needed that though
and so how did you come back from that
time that's when i wrote another email
and i was like i'm [ __ ] off team usa
i'm not [ __ ] i'm not done with usa
judo i'm done with the tour i was like i
quit go i'm gonna go do my own thing
they were like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
can't quit now the olympics is in like a
year like let's talk about this again
because it's the second time i've tried
to quit in like two years
right
so then we sit down in jimmy's office
and he's like whoa whoa whoa you can't
quit you're gonna kick yourself if you
don't go to rio i'm telling you right
now don't do that to yourself
let's figure out a way of like doing
this and i was like
because when we trained before we did it
as a unit
right we all went to the same
tournaments we all went to the same
training camps and i'm like you guys are
treating me like i'm the same player i
used to be i go i don't
i'm not operating at the level you think
i'm operating at i go i can't do that
and he goes well what do you want to do
and i'll tell you what jimmy you know
i'm being serious because my answer is
something you'd never would have
expected i go i want you to send me to
japan for three weeks
and he was like
really i hated japan i refused to go
there up until this point
but i was like i have to get to a point
where i can get so tired
and get through it
that like my judo will come back and my
body will learn again and uh when you
say japan you meet the kodokan like what
what
is that the highest level of judo
it's one of the top colleges in the
world yeah and that's so you can go with
the best people in the world you can go
to war with them top level like strong
players yeah there's a lot of very
strong players there's a lot of middle
class players and there's a lot of
volume of rounds
so you value all of it the middle class
too like that because when you're tired
like you can't just train in areas where
you're
you're battling for every inch at some
point you have to be successful
right so you still under duress and
under strain and
through exhaustion you still have to
have the ability to score yeah well if
you're training with the best people in
the world all the time you're not always
going to be able to score so you still
need those b level players in order to
really develop again
what is it like if you can comment
briefly on um
training in japan what's it like to go
into a different place
you probably don't speak the language
that well
um like is there an isolation aspect to
it is it like purely about judo now
i really wanted to be isolated no
training partners no coaches
i wanted to get back to my roots and
just learn how to fight again
i don't want to figure out how to beat
the german i don't want to figure out
how i can develop a new entry into my
sale against
you know
whoever it may be it's not you're just
going to fight hard
let me get back to fighting let me get
back to like
the root of who i am what were those
sessions like what we were talking about
five-minute rounds like what what how
many six six minute rounds 30-minute
breaks 14 rounds of session
sorry what's the 30-minute break 30 30
seconds 30 seconds 30 second break
sorry what 14 14 rounds 14 rounds every
day
every day
five five days a week and then 11 or 12
rounds on saturday
plus weightlifting plus running
plus weightlifting plus running so that
those are hard rounds yeah what's it
feel like to go through that so you have
a bunch of uh just a sea of black belts
japan
i'm sure they're hunting you a little
bit
depending on who you are i was hunted a
little bit like i didn't really struggle
because of who i am
them as college athletes
they want to show to their coaches and
their you know higher players like oh
look i can throw the world number
whoever
but if you're just a guy who shows up
like
them beating you doesn't provide any
value or raise their status no but your
your status raising yes
so i was actually like
in a situation where nobody was watching
me
and i was free to just battle at my own
will okay
which is what it was about for me and
you just pushed yourself because i knew
how to do that i know how to push myself
are you uh when you're doing these 14
rounds is every single one
a standalone thing for you yep so you're
not trying to pace yourself nope it's
just each one is to as much exhaustion
as i can get but then there must be ones
that were like it's like round nine
where you're got nothing left better
figure out how to score
it's all you got to do
you got to survive you gotta score
what's your memories of that of those
three weeks what's like what stands out
to you
it seems like um
because that's the place where you found
the silver medal
because it's the place most people don't
want to be
everybody's comfortable
i would rather
i would rather find out who i am and
what i'm made of and find those
those endpoints and if i can't find them
then
that means everybody else has given up
before me
were there a few people that just kind
of you returned to battle over and over
in those times and then it was just
yep
no social media
no none of that is just like to
lock yourself in your room you come back
you've thought about it
and you come back with a game plan for
that day
against some players here or there and i
would i would develop a hit list
like i would be like oh that that
[ __ ] grabbed me at like 13 and i
watched him sit [ __ ] four rounds and
then come try to kick the [ __ ] out of me
i'm gonna [ __ ] grab that guy early
and i'm gonna beat the [ __ ] at him
and you just developed that list there's
probably some epic battles in that room
right yeah
uh what's it look like like how crowded
is it barry and so you're just like
yeah it's a sea of people see a people
and you're trying to are you doing
groundwork at all just throws just
throws your throats no transitions no
nothing but if i get pissed off and like
you keep dropping or like not let me do
what i want to do i'll rip a choke right
across your face yeah just to let you
know that like
yeah and if i wanted to you have a
really nice style of just like
respectfully
bullying the [ __ ] out of people because
some people call me a bully and i have
to remind them that like
a bully enjoys like
beating up the weak right i want to beat
the person that fights back
right exactly it's not fun for me if you
don't fight back right
some of the greatest people i've seen
like do this they they basically uh you
have this in the iowa wrestling rooms
they'll push each other into the wall
like they get there's like anger but
it's ultimately underneath it all it's
like a deep respect i was training with
colton brown one time and i went to san
jose state because i was in california
for something
and he kept like he kept circling to the
edge
they had like a cupboard that had like
when you opened it it had like all the
tape and like medical supplies i was
like i'll [ __ ] put you right through
that and he kind of lit he kind of
giggled and then he went by that edge
and i [ __ ] ran him right through it
yeah see to me that's an ultimate sign
of respect that both you and colton will
yeah remember well and we're still
friends we still talk it's just i told
him i was going to do it he knew i meant
it too yeah he did it anyways
that's just testing me
uh
yeah
listen that's and that same attitude was
that's that was in japan just day after
day after day after day yep 14 rounds
that's that's rough
uh and you didn't sit out rounds and i
did it all with a broken hand
uh how
wow
how did you do with the broken hand you
show up every day you show up okay i
actually one left to right my right
okay so that's okay so you can then
focus on gripping with your left
it's always the way
there's always a way but that means you
can't i guess you don't have to grip
your right sometimes because i would
palm it with my thumb just like hanging
out like this just like this so you can
do something so you could do like a gosh
because you have a
um cause
what were your main throws it was sanagi
koshigoroma
okay
sumi uchimata
but you have this big uh
um like a goshi type of thing like a
yeah but not from like around the waist
it's from over the shoulder over the
shoulder and i can do it with just the
one hand
oh as i wish one hand the right one i
don't need the sleeve hand you don't
need a sleeve hand but you couldn't do
with the broken hand i could
because i can just put my hand in the
key so it can't come off
and then you just
because what happened was
three days before i was leaving for
japan a guy my hand was rested like this
on a mat and the guy
boom took my whole thumb off and tore
all the tendons in the palm yeah so when
i went to the doctor he was like
you know do we have to put a cast on and
i go i'm leaving in three days you know
you're not putting a cast on it and i go
this is what i want you to do just like
this i said i want you to build a cast
that holds it
that velcros around so that when i'm not
training i can wear it yeah but then
when i'm training
i'll take it off and then i'll put the
tape on it and then whatever happens
happens
whatever happens
happens all right so that's epic and
that led you to the 2016 olympics in rio
well that led me to winning pan am gold
when i got back from japan
and then almost getting my leg cut off
in 2015.
that was like
maybe a month or two later
i was hospitalized for seven days
the leg being cut off for what i had
three different types of bacterial
infections in my right leg my whole leg
swelled
and it was in my blood skin and in my
bone
my right leg
so i got stuck at mgh in a hospital for
seven days until they figured out
what the bacteria source was
where was the source of the infection as
in in my knee in the knee yeah
okay so obviously there's a danger of
like that's life-threatening yep when i
went into the emergency room when i got
back from the worlds the lady was like
hey you you need to call you're gonna
call cause you may lose your leg tonight
yeah and then they put me in the
hospital
what do you think in this whole time
are you still thinking about olympics
they put me into the room like four
hours later the doctor came in
um
i was at mgh in boston
and he was like
you have a serious infection in your leg
i go he's like we have to keep you
hospitalized until we can figure out
what it is and i was like buddy i have
the olympic games in less than a year i
go i don't give a [ __ ] what it is i go
just [ __ ] take it out and let me get
on with my day he goes we can't do that
i'm like i don't understand i go you
told me it's infected just cut away that
part of the tissue drain it do whatever
you got to do and then send me on my way
he's like it doesn't work like that he
said until we figure out what it is we
can't figure out how to stop it from
growing or how far it spread so it took
him seven days to figure out what it was
then once they figured out what it was i
went in for surgery to remove it
then i spent i think it was eight weeks
in in-home care with a picc line
and then i came back from that
in the first week and a half of judo i
tore my si joint
trying to throw a guy
and then i came back from that about a
month
later and then
fifth at the kano cup and then the game
six months later how quickly do doctors
understand who they're dealing with
like is that is that difficult for you
to explain who travis stevens is when
you go to visit a doctor i don't think
they understand
you know
their role
is to get me to do my job to the best of
their ability as a doctor right meaning
it's going to be less than what they
want
and they and they struggle conceptually
with like
but the textbook tells me this
and i go but i'm not a textbook
right like when you go to physical
therapy the first thing they do is they
pull out that binder that says day one
we do this exercise
i go but i have my own goals yeah your
job is to help me meet my goal
let's let's work a plan to do that or i
gotta go find somebody else
did the doctors in general people
outside of your close-knit group step up
if they didn't i found somebody else
and typically i could find a person who
knew the right person
i always wonder with people like because
i'm i'm constantly surrounded by
one of the biggest problems in my life
has been there's a lot of people in my
life who love me very much
but who want me to the equivalent of
that situation um
you know definitely don't go to the
olympics and definitely like take like
it seems like the world is full of
people that want you to be
average and happy
which is great which is fine i mean i
perhaps that's the way it should be
like you know my parents people close to
this that's what love
how love manifests itself often in
people but then like i think the
ultimate
manifestation of love is understanding
who this person is here's a madman who's
driven towards a particular thing and
the best thing for you to do is not to
say
like
rest is to say
work harder
like
[ __ ] your infection yeah you should be
training yeah
have you ever met anybody as crazy as
you that can help you most of us who
get to this point get there because
we're all a little unstable yeah even my
wife khalida right like
when she was getting ready for 2016
um or when she was getting ready for
2020 because she moved to boston
to be a coach she
had a
neck problem
right
and
[Music]
at that at some point in time it's like
what's really important
day-to-day life
or judo
and believe it or not
the doctor in canada was like
i am never under any circumstances doing
an mri of your neck again
that's what she told her she goes if you
have me do an mri yeah you're not doing
judo again so just know if you hurt your
neck and it requires an mri
you're done with judo forever yeah so
decide if you want to do judo or not
that was a conversation we actually had
to have that's a cool thing for a doctor
to say
i mean it depends how badass they sound
when they say it
so that's a tough conversation judo won
what's what's this
with your wife what's that relationship
like so you're both a little crazy
a little bit in a good sense
or from my perspective in a good sense
yeah it's just we've
we understand that when it
when you set a goal to do something
you're not signing on for the good
yeah you're signing on for the bad
and i don't think a lot of people
understand that
that's like a valentine's day card from
travis stevens
you have to like accept everything
negative that could possibly happen and
until you do you're never gonna make it
because you'll always sell yourself
short yeah you'll never go far enough
and if you sign up for the whole thing
then the negative is just like oh great
i expected that if you're experiencing
the negative they're also experienced
the negative
and if you overcome it maybe they'll get
knocked out from yep maybe they won't
deal with it maybe they won't train
through it
right when i had my five herniated disc
and i was in a neck brace i was still in
the gym at 7am yeah doing whatever it is
i could do because my job is to be at
the gym
david goggins i don't know if you know
the guy he's he's gone he's damaged lots
of parts of his body like you
trying to achieve things so you know
unlike you
his achievements are like
your achievements come with a medal
he's just running in the darkness in the
middle of nowhere by himself it's like i
mean it's the same probably as with you
if you're able to be introspective about
it is he's just battling his own inner
demons and
working through those and he's breaking
up breaking his body doing so
are you cognizant of the trade-off of
the fact that you know you're damaging
your body
to get to these levels of achievements
of this level of excellence of this
level of greatness i mean i guess that
depends on what you consider damage
really because
i don't really see that i have damaged
my body if anything i think i've
strengthened it
my body can go through more than yours
can yeah whose is weaker
yeah right it's just like
it's just like the thai boxers right
yeah in order to strengthen their shins
they got to break it a few times yeah
it's just nature the beast you just uh
had to break a bunch of stuff to find
where the weak points are and then made
them stronger yep of course strengthen
the areas around it to strengthen it by
you know the sheer relation to it but
the problem is like you may not be able
to do judo
like for until you're 70. why not
i may not be able to do judo to the
level i used to yeah don't get me wrong
but i can still do judo because and i
think a lot of people struggle with
they want to keep doing it like they
used to be able to do it i don't try to
do judo like i used to like you're
seeing here yeah i'm not that guy
anymore
i accept that i don't even try to be
that guy anymore
i'm a completely different player today
than i am when i was winning olympic
medals
and so i guess when you're looking at
like my journey and the trade-off is
i never sacrificed anything
the people around me sacrificed for me
and i never had a downturn after the
olympics because i never identified as
an olympian
you know a lot of olympians suffer from
depression because they identify as it
now they don't have who they are
where was your personal
moment of greatness
like
or do you not experience life that way
where you were truly proud to be
yourself like every day i wake up
uh you wake up and you're not proud of
who you are then
you've really got to seek out some like
help so that's first of all okay i'll
i'll do that because um i definitely am
not proud
of who i am i just wonder if you didn't
identify with the olympics
was there times
maybe in the training room maybe in
japan
like where you're all
you just kind of felt like
i get more of an
emotional i guess trigger right where
like i feel proud of what i've done
when
i've
set to a task and i've done it
so almost any task and the more
challenging the tasks the more reward
you